god I kept telling myself I had a lot of
time to write a speech and that was even
this morning I was like I have so much
time even having a beer a little while
ago I was like I just want to before I
think anybody just say that I share this
award this honor
entirely with my producer and classmate
and friend Lilly knew and the DP of this
project
John Wakayama Carrie who is a total
genius I think when we were when we were
sitting together in the hotel lobby of
the weird I don't know I think we're
just like looking at each other like
when we have this idea thing that there
was no way that this was ever gonna work
and I think we we got something pretty
good out of it um I want to thank the
Academy for the gift of this week it's
been amazing and to all the fellow
winners here they're just the best the
best people in their films are super
inspiring I want to say thank you
specifically to Mary general and
professor rend who made the this film
possible I want to thank my family my my
father James my my mom Kathy and my
sisters Alicia and Corinne Kelly who's
just endless love and support has
allowed me to wander all the way up to
this stage and I want to thank the
people at Columbia University it's a
tremendous honor to go to that school
in particular I want to thank Eric
Mendelssohn who was my advisor who
helped shape this film and I wanted to
thank Christina Lazzarini who at late in
the stage read my script and had the
courage to tell me that it was terrible
and that I should throw it out and start
over
and I did and I think it made all the
difference
and I want to thank my classmates at
Columbia but those who have graduated in
those who are still there they are some
of the finest most inspiring filmmakers
that I've ever met and they pushed me to
work harder and they're just phenomenal
people so thank you I also want to say
thank you to Anita who plays the madam
in this film she's here and she's just
the best so thank you thank you so much